[Music]
Univision now is our direct consumer
subscription offering and the goal was
to give access to our audience wherever
they are whenever they wanted when we
really wanted to innovate and push the
boundaries on our subscription service
we launched in app subscriptions for
Google Places and we saw a pop
immediately about three to four times
the conversion rate by working with the
Google team when we started a Nogami
we said we want to have a music service
which is convenient and all the music
available in the Middle East it was a
region which was totally forgotten there
was no legal eternity so you have to
fight it or hide it I mean there was
nothing else and if we actually could
succeed with the piloting the pilot for
us we'd play is the core we have over 81
percent of our users today on Android
our growth strategy goes around engaging
Android users to use up more so they can
subscribe making that Google Play
billing when you have increase of
subscription conversion rate on a Nike
net and we think that the main
connection in the better user experience
Android ID from the main source for
download : acting up
also we've seen on subscription
conversion and increase of X percent on
Android and compared to other problems
really started with a vision to make
everyone the greatest version of
themselves and the way we do this that
we're trying to motivate and lighten the
variety of apps to reach their physical
and mental goals the reason why is
absolutely make a lot of sense for us
it's not only community on the point of
view but also because we want to develop
it in the long run we want to have a
repeated impact on their life working
with Google Play and figuring out how to
launch a successful subscription product
it's been great and that kind of
partnership is really what we saw that
led to the success
you
[Music]